this is breaking news huge developing
story
Scooby-Doo's Velma Dinkley finally
confirmed as lesbian in new trick or
treat film as new female love interest
is introduced that's it I know all of
your Velma fantasies are over everybody
your weird Velma fetishes they're done
she is officially a lady lover they have
confirmed it well there goes my chances
in Velma with a non-existent cartoon
character dang it so I just I don't know
I saw the story I thought it was funny
because Mike why
that just no sir why all right is Velma
does Velma need to be attracted to
someone for a character to work because
like is there a reason why after what
it's been like 50 years because they
lean too heavily on gender and sexuality
and explosions now and they don't have
good storylines anymore so they're gonna
pull in a whole different demographic of
people to watch it who are like oh I
feel obscene it's my representation
representation is important I mean real
quick real quick uh for those big
Scooby-Doo fans has sexuality been a
component of the show at all never is
Fred going like hey baby and you know
something like that I mean they did the
live action Scooby-Doo with um uh I
don't even remember Freddie Prince yeah
and
um um Sarah Michelle Geller uh Matthew
Lillard and I don't know please yeah
yeah but like I think the larger
question is was there any was there any
tension in that like Johnny Bravo Mama I
think so that would be the closest they
were like gags and stuff but I I the
reason I bring this up this question is
because
Scooby-Doo's for kids why is Velma like
I I've not I mean oh you know what no
there was Scooby had a girlfriend didn't
he in like one of the movies did he but
there's like not a big sexual component
of Scooby-Doo to begin with so this is
just out of place period for the show
like you don't you don't see it like in
the cartoon it's like
almost every single episode of the show
ever is that some dude is trying to
lower property value by pretending to be
a ghost or a mummy or something and then
they're like he was trying to scam
people just shows you that the monsters
are adults and the monsters are you know
scammers yeah
but I guess that's the lesson but now
it's monsters are people the whole time
and film is gay yeah that's it yeah well
because you need accurate representation
the producers of Scooby-Doo is it you
know Harvey Weinstein
why are they interjecting sexual
preference in a kid's movie I think
everyone should be asking themselves
well Disney also does a lot of sinister
subliminal messages and and and puts
wieners everywhere so they have a
horrible track record especially with a
lot of their younger stars but
um as Tim pulled up here there's there's
well I think I think we need to point
out that shaggy is trans it's been been
that way right I I've I've seen if my
fair share of Scooby-Doo I mean it's
been around it's older than I am and I'm
like Shaggy's been dressing like like a
lady for a while like it's a common
Trope in the Scooby-Doo series and so I
gotta wonder if these doctors are saying
that kids who play with dolls or want to
dress like girls are trans maybe
Shaggy's trying to tell us something or
the producer trying to tell something
about Shaggy
I was looking back at this and I was
like oh there's cross-dressing in every
kid's movie why is this like because it
was a joke seriously yeah
like in The Lion King you have to Timon
who's like what do you want me to do
dress and drag and do the hula and the
next scene he's in drag doing the hula
you know and it's it's comical because
it's like oh well that's funny but now
it's like that's not funny
yeah it can't be fun it can't be funny
anymore
Linda Cardellini played Velma in the
live action see I don't know who that is
because I can tell you like Freddie
Prince Junior Matthew Lillard and Sarah
Michelle Geller are famous enough to him
like I remember who they were but like I
have no idea who this lady is did she
like did she do other stuff after this
because I don't know she was a lesbian
honestly Velma yeah look at her yeah we
have one look at this guy we have one
velma's a lesbian with impeccable taste
congratulations you won that was yours
uh Velma also uh calls the police on
people in that video game
multiverses and it caused a huge outrage
because they were like it's racist to
call the cops I guess and people were
posting videos this is a fighting game
you guys hear about multiverses and you
can play as like Warner Brothers
characters say like Batman Shaggy Velma
is a character and so is LeBron and
velma's special ability was to call the
police and then a police car arrests you
and then drives off the edge
yeah exactly they were calling her a
Karen saying yeah she was like you're in
big trouble now and the squad car grabs
the person and like people are posting
videos of LeBron getting arrested and
then people were even leftists were
tweeting like yo is this like kind of
weird that velma's arresting this black
guy and then the squad car drives off
the cliff and then he dies that's how
the game works
yeah
so you won Nama is allows me but she's
also a Karen I lost because my chances
with Velma I'm forever gone I never get
to dream about it well it's always kind
of been a dynamic between
um lgbtq and uh you know black lives
matter like especially in June you know
and then when they have like their month
and then every like every time the uh
LGBT or black lives matter would get
something it would always be like they'd
have to share it and I remember this
being like a big controversy between the
two different factions that so there is
always something between the two I don't
know if they're trying to pit it against
each other or what it is but they also
tried saying that Samus from Metroid was
a trans trans woman salmon so uh yeah
yeah Samus so uh you guys know the game
Metroid it's uh originally it's like it
was nes and you're a person wearing this
the suit and you you know shoot from
your hand or whatever and then do flips
and at the end if you get the good
ending it reveals that the character
Samus was a woman whole time and like
Nintendo she takes the helmet off and
there's blonde hair and was like ah
reveal and so then throughout the years
you know the character has been
developed and metroid's got a ton of
games and Sam Samus in the Metroid suit
or whatever it's called is in Smash
Brothers and they were saying like this
proves that Samus is actually a trans
woman the whole time they're trying to
change the character the problem was
there's like a bunch of Art and Samus
zero suit Samus is the character in
Smash Brothers and it's like that's a
chick it's like it's overtly a woman
with you know big tits and and a butt so
instead of being like um oh look at what
women can achieve you know it's like no
it was a man the whole time who you know
is the woman this is actually a male oh
yeah man of the year oh yeah a trans
woman yeah so I beat you in all the
sports too this is the thing you know
like one of the tweets here was uh what
is this is this James Gunn someone said
please make our live-action lesbian
Velma dreams come true since I tried in
2001. all right Trident One Velma was
explicitly gay in my initial script the
studio just kept watering it down and
watering it down becoming ambiguous the
version then nothing and finally having
a boyfriend in the sequel oh so actually
velma's bi like canonically if in the
movie she had a boyfriend and she likes
girls she's not a lesbian so guys you
you are incorrect but um someone said
Velma being gay is actually massive
we're at a point in time when this major
character full of decades-old history
and fans gets to actually be a lesbian
and that's just another part of her
Canon now sometimes we need to celebrate
these wins I just don't understand why
it's like don't you want your own
characters
so we were talking about the other the
other night back they can't make people
famous anymore this is like the ability
to make celebrities is weakening and
like the ability to create content and
characters has failed nobody wants to
make it make a uh here's a character
armadillo guy like Batman it's like
Batman over and over and over again
every movie Spider-man Batman Spider-man
that's all they ever do make armadillo
man someone's probably already done it
okay how about how like what's an
obscure animal ostrich dude yeah and um
you know he's a guy who does like an
ostrich there you go yeah Stan Lee had
actually come out and said that you know
like the way he wrote his characters he
wrote them specifically like he wrote
people like you know and he was attached
to people you know so you get like
Mary Jane for instance a redhead let's
go into redhead Erasure you know that's
something I hear a lot about but um you
know like but but they just reimagined
the characters as being different than
who who they were created to be at their
Foundation well I'm I'm really upset
about The Little Mermaid because they
put an actress and ginger face yes
that's right
it's very disrespectful to the Irish
people it is that we highly respect here
on the show of course uh but also more
importantly uh uh more importantly I I
wish characters in in entertainment
actually have personalities actually had
interesting story lines instead of just
like hey this is my sexual preference
because we're seeing that more and more
and more and it's like okay who are you
as a real person who are you when when
it comes people to their sexuality or
their race and it's damn do you guys
think this is going to reduce
profitability of these shows because I
mean like Netflix right they got woke
they're going broke right
um oh they're bleeding subscribers and I
bet it's because a lot of people are
jumping [ __ ] yeah people don't want to
either way even if they support the
movements it's like I just want I don't
want it to be political at all or it's
not that I think we we do want to a
certain degree some Politics on our
content but subtle and
um what's the right word balanced there
was a video a viral video from some show
Boston Legal maybe it was and it was um
it might have been James Spader and
William Shannon I could be wrong and
their their friends William Shatner's I
think it's chat nerd's better I could be
wrong but I think Shatner is like the
the mentor to this younger guy who's a
liberal and he's a Republican and then
they make a joke about each other being
Republican and liberal and then smile
and look off into the sunset or whatever
like that's the kind of politics where
we're like oh yeah you know like express
your idea challenge the idea and then
have a nuanced conversation we don't get
that now it's just like are you a bigot
you know let's just that's just it it's
just overt over the top one dimensional
for what reason is Velma is Velma
sexuality a component of the show it
doesn't need to be but
because they reduce people to their
sexuality now I mean look I get it you
are but they've done Scooby having a
girlfriend or whatever and then like
Shaggy had a girlfriend but it turned
out she was an alien I guess yeah I
can't remember what movie that was but
there's been there's so much Scooby-Doo
stuff but like it ends with him being
like zoing she was like an alien the
whole time like so is the dog the dog
so like no they've done weird stuff but
my point is just like as we as we say it
all the time shouldn't you just make a
new character shouldn't you just write
news stories and then the other the
other issue is
why would I want like if if you know if
you were if if you're gonna have your
kids watch something why would you want
them to watch
this kind of stuff so I don't think that
this is any longer a child show I think
and I will say I'm gonna have the
controversial take after giving it some
thought I think it's fine that they have
a lesbian representation in the show
because I don't know if you guys are
familiar with the lesbian bar scene
probably not I don't know why I am for
sure there's like two left in the entire
country lesbians don't count anymore if
you'll recall lesbians were last being
called transphobic for not wanting to
engage in certain facts right they're
turfs because they're just lesbians they
like other women like biological women
but the features of biological women and
I think that this is actually a positive
thing because I don't I don't think that
Scooby-Doo is a children's show anymore
I think it's a relic of an older
generation so this is like them Reviving
Hocus Pocus right yeah it's for older
people it's not really for kids and I
think the lesbian representation is good
so I've been I've been talking about I
talked about this I was talking about
that Meme with Abe Simpson where he's
like you know I used to be with it but
then they changed what it was and now
what is is scary and it'll happen to you
too and I was like that's not gonna
happen to us it's not going to happen to
us because people aren't having kids
that means gen Alpha is going to be
smaller and that means gen double Elf or
whatever comes next is going to be even
smaller beta
listen listen so what's going to happen
is we're all gonna be 50 or 60 or
whatever and and we're all going to be
working and producing still and
Millennials aren't going to have kids
and then you're gonna get a big promoter
who says we want to do a show a rock
concert and we want to make the most
money and they're going to say oh yeah
the generation beta artist he can
attract about 20 million people but the
millennial artist is going to bring in
75 why there are more Millennials yeah
it is yep it's just it it's a market
size thing it used to be that the new
generation was always slightly bigger
than the last so it was always more
profitable to Target the Next Generation
because it's a bigger market share when
they move in the key demo but now you're
gonna have 18 to 35 year olds there's
going to be 20 million of them and
there's going to be 7 many million
Millennials or whatever and they're
going to be like what's the point the
market share is microscopic don't pan to
these people and they're going to have
to live in the shadow of the millennial
and gen Z's Generations positive because
then they're going to have to create
their own culture they're gonna have to
make their own art they're gonna have to
develop their own music Styles I think
it's this is where we break from
corporatism so I'm feeling very
optimistic about this I mean we'll see
if I'm correct like we'll have to wait
for a few years but I think you're right
because it is never gonna change because
now I think gen Z is the largest
demographic right now I was reading
something about that yesterday and then
I think after that it's gonna super
taper off
um because uh gen Z is the product of
genetics right mostly Gen X yeah yeah
and then uh I don't think I think the
oldest Millennial they're not what's the
youngest gen Z
let's say like 12 15. okay so the
Millennials could have gen Z kids if
like the oldest Millennials but it's
mostly like a Gen X thing I think my
kids are gen Z yeah I think so yeah I
think because they're jinsi there you go
yeah so Jen Alpha is going to be tiny
yeah
yeah we'll see maybe gen Z has like a
revolt against you know Millennials and
gen x's and they're like you're lame
we're gonna have 50 kids and go to
church that seems to be what happens I
mean if you look at like even the 80s
like uh you know they were the product
of the hippies and they all went and
became Republicans you know like it was
it was their way to lash out against
their hippie parents thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there